PROFESSOR: Here are the
differential equations
for the angular momentum
of a tumbling box.
Try throwing a book, or a box,
or any rectilinear object whose
three dimensions are all
different, into the air
with a twist, to make a tumble.
You could go to rotate
about its longest axis,
or about its shortest axis.
But you can't get to rotate
about its middle axis.
Let's examine that
phenomena numerically.
Here's the anonymous
function defining
those system of three first
order differential equations.
Now I'm going to start with
an initial condition that's
near the first critical point.
1, 0, 0 is a critical point.
And I'm going to take 0.2
times a random number,
to sort of be near the critical
point, and then normalize it,
so that it has length 1.
So the largest component
is the first component.
And the other two are
small, but not too small.
This is an easy
problem numerically.
There's no stiffness
involved here.
So I'm going to use ODE
23, integrate from 0 to 10,
and here's the solution.
The blue component is the
first one, and it stays near 1.
And the other two are periodic,
rotating around the 0.
Let's go back and take
another starting condition.
Here it is again.
Now the other two
components are really small.
And when we integrate
that, the blue component
stays flat near 1.
And the other two guys
hardly move at all.
Now I'm going to go to the
third critical point, 0, 0, 1.
Do the same thing.
Take a random number near there.
Use ODE 23.
Now the yellow component
stays near one.
And the other two move
periodically around 0.
Run that again.
The third component is near 1.
The other two are not too big.
And run the ODE 23.
The other component
stays near 1.
And the other two rotate
periodically around 0.
Now we're going to go to
the middle critical point.
We're going to try and get
the box to rotate around
its middle axis.
The second component
is the one near 1.
And now we see completely
different behavior.
This sienna component
doesn't stay near 1.
It goes down near -1,
and comes back up.
Let's integrate over
a longer period,
so we can see that behavior.
So it's periodic.
But it goes down to -1
and comes back to 1.
And the other two move in
large amplitudes around 0.
So this is the instability of
that middle critical value.
Let's doing again.
Same thing.
1 down to -1, and back up.
It's periodic.
These solutions
are all periodic.
But that middle critical
point is unstable.
Now I want to view these in
a different way, graphically.
The differential equations have
these three critical points.
Any solutions to start exactly
in these initial conditions
stay there.
But what happens if you start
near these initial conditions?
Well it turns out, that x and
z are stable critical points.
But y is an unstable
critical point.
If the angular momentum
is near x or near z,
it stays near there.
But if it starts near y,
it moves away quickly.
You can think of x as the short
axis, and z is the long axis.
Rotation near the
short axis is stable.
And rotation near the
long axis a stable.
But rotation near the
middle axis is unstable.
We can see that in
the following graphic.
It turns out that
if a solution starts
with an initial condition
that has norm 1,
it stays with norm 1.
So the solution lives
on the unit sphere.
Here's our unit share with our
three critical points, x, y,
and z.
If this were the Earth,
z will be the North Pole.
Axis where the 0-th meridian
crosses the equator.
That's in the east Atlantic,
a little off of West Africa.
y would be where the 90th
meridian crosses the equator.
That's in the Indian
Ocean, west of Sumatra.
If we start with an
initial condition near x,
the solution orbits around x.
That's stable rotation
around the short axis.
If we start with an
initial condition near z,
the solution orbits around z.
That's stable rotation
around the long axis.
But if we start
near y, the solution
takes off, goes over to
near -y, turns around,
and comes back to y.
Periodic, but goes
clear around the globe.
That turns out, that's a circle
actually, an orbit around x.
If we come up a little above
y, we get an orbit around z.
Go down a little below y,
we get an orbit around -z.
Go to the right of y, we
get an orbit around -x.
Let's zoom in a little bit.
And we can see that y is a
classic unstable critical
point.
Let's conclude by
drawing a few orbits.